did you find that you face the strongest  opposition from the community or from  here in the states oh from the community  within the community i mean it's just  it's  i have heard that in  poorer  or in an indigenous communities that  when one person or one small group is  seen to be  going ahead or getting more  opportunities or money or whatever it is  that  the tendency is to try to bring that  that group or that person down and i  think that's all that was  it's just seen as a well here's a big  school and  we want it  because resources are scarce  fighting they fight it's easy to fall  into that  but i think the heart the the continuous  line that i always have to write i  always have to walk is  is  not to  tell people what to do  i can't do that and i want to do that a  lot of times  but i think growing up in japan helped  me with that because i see  things as an outsider my husband says  i'm very i'm most happy or comfortable  when i'm an outsider